spaces so let's make one let's make one
I want ready what's up everybody today
we are going to the house once again
we've visited the house so much recently
thanks to the holidays really good like
there's nothing else to do for the
holidays you have your meals you have
your conversations and family and then
can you do that for like six hours a day
and you're kind of like what else should
we do over this holiday we decided to go
visit the house a lot a lot more than we
visited this house more recently than we
have ever in the past two months
usually we go once a week families here
we're like no and then they're still
working on the house like we're not
seeing any progress so true
you just like to make sense
all of the house even more because
Norman
like division
I've been like intern
like recently like yesterday we went was
it yesterday or two days ago we went
every yeah we've practically gone every
day but like yeah we started like
measuring certain dimensions of the
rooms taking sharp edge
today we're probably gonna measure the
windows so we can figure out what kind
of window treatments we need for blinds
and stuff and
just figuring out other ways to spend
more money on the house I just keep
seeing pictures and stuff just trying to
show me on her phone and I'm like god
damn it I need to see their person Oh
[Music]
dope are showers done the extra space
that square footage that we lose from
here we gave it up their home I mean
we're a little bit check for like six
years
shift the starter home now issue of our
laundry room because in the house we
currently live in we don't even have a
laundry room
[Music]
taking jess on a tour of all the
different floor plans they got here and
there's development going through the
pros and cons and justifying why our
floor plan is the bed
[Music]
we are now at chick-fil-a and we're
gonna fill up with some quick snacks
quick meal and right after this what are
we about to do
we're gonna meet baby Enzo I can't wait
but yeah we're gonna be baby Enzo
which is Christina's newborn baby boy
I'm so excited we got a stop back to get
some flowers
I always get flowers - no - ain't cool
we get the siendo meet Enzo before the
baby showers Hannibal oh really
we got them a car seat I knew that I
have good oh my goodness my big sister
big sister Congrats Congrats mr. Ferrari
okay hi Enzo
say hi everybody there's so much noise
going on but he's going to look like
yeah not you yeah I he might he might
look more like Cristina yeah I don't
know it looks like this year I don't
know where you got the small eyes room
maybe it just hasn't grown in that the
features that I'm saying yeah yeah but
you know what it's funny you brought
that up cuz me and TIFF we're looking at
the Leia's babe baby baby put videos and
stuff and like she already had like the
structure like the eyes and stuff that
looks like you
[Music]
Wow he's like who are you what are you
recognize my voice don't you its nearing
this thang I
[Music]
[Music]
that's what you have right now true and
a boy in a hole yeah wait so a boy and a
girl character in Chinese turns into ho
yes song together
not like ho as an American ho which is
what anti we got a ho but always that
it's the work we're good and and it's
really cool a lot of people I get to try
and they only get got boys or they only
get good
for them to have a boy and girl is a
pretty cool deal
[Music]
say hi brother I want to give a brother
[Music]
[Music]
you ready for this not leaving without
that your case might be like your old
posture rows of 10 are really tense
right don't mess up okay hi dude little
hat yeah babies like to know moving
you're just like lightly move your arms
like not you don't have to move your
whole body cuz you're so tense
[Applause]
Leah Oh daddy's gonna clean you up let's
make one let's make one I want one ready
I've been ready man I'm ready - I've
been ready - well I mean it's been an
interesting year yeah it's been a lot a
lot a lot has happened this year that's
prevented one of these to be made
forever I know right
Oh smell him smell beer and you have
your own you'll be better and productive
in your stare at the baby true I
remember I used to just stare at Isaac
for hours and he was sleeping I'd be so
exhausted I'm like you're just so
perfect to look at okay let's you
sometimes wondering while are they
thinking yeah making funny faces they
move their face heavy stennes oh he
doesn't have colored eyes true even with
us we've been married for a minute right
how long have you were you guys married
when you had Leah how long we've been
married for seven years ten years from
today I asked you to be my girlfriend
Oh
countdown countdown oh yeah that's so
cute always party yeah he's all farting
he's like talking say hi she totally be
say hi everybody
yeah she looks like you here she's
singing up to how to do the job
yeah yeah are you yeah that's so you
turn it this way your email you can
everyone look at oh you have everyone
now yes say hi everybody welcome to
where's baby you want to show them baby
baby actually really uh-huh
what do you this belly and
you gotta show your face okay want to
give everyone a kiss kiss everybody kiss
kiss all right we are now eating dinner
with his family just family
my brothers and my mom we got mama and
father have dinner after visiting Enzo
and then just went home she's not
joining us what's interesting was today
started off as a day where we didn't
really plan much and then I don't know a
lot not now that we were nearing the end
of the day I'm like we did so much that
we went to go see the house we met up
which s had a whole day which s actually
in the met up with aunt Kristina Enzo
met a baby and and like we're like
probably like within the first 10 people
he's ever met that's kind of cool Enzo
if you're watching in the future
we were like the first bridge do gay
people you met
[Music]